that report from DWS Melanie credible
and she joins us from her re with more
on the story hi Melanie good to see you
so voting is underway this is an
historic election was the first as we
said without former President Robert
Mugabe how significant is this day for
the people that you've been speaking to
there sue me it's a very significant day
for the almost 6 million voters here in
Zimbabwe I'm in Harare at one of the
polling stations and look at these
queues behind me they are massive people
have been queuing from 4:00 a.m. in the
morning at 7 a.m. is when the when the
polling station opened and people here
are really excited they feel like this
is the first election that could
potentially be free and transparent and
that their vote this time around will
really count
well Mugabe himself has hardly been seen
or heard of since his ouster but Melanie
he made a surprise appearance as we said
in front of the cameras the night before
voting and he turned against his
successor president Emerson mangog well
let's listen to what he said is I knew
Pierre I can't put presenter Pierre so
what what is there I think it's just
jamesha Melanie why are we seeing Mugabe
here turn against his successor and his
former ally well let's remember he did
not leave the political stage
voluntarily he was ousted by the
military and now someone who once was on
his side is running for president so of
course he is quite resentful he's been
saying there are so many names on the
ballot paper there 23 but my name is not
on it and that is very painful he also
said that his party has become
undemocratic and unconstitutional which
is quite a strong statement considering
that he ruled the country in what was
essentially a dictatorship for almost
four decades and he's not particularly
popular with a lot of people in Zimbabwe
right now is his apparent endorsement of
Nelson chalisa going to hurt his chances
you can actually not underestimate how
much of a political sway he still has
with some parts of the population there
are some people who are still supporting
Susanoo PS no matter what but there are
also some people who really supported
Mugabe
and if he's the one saying that he will
not vote from under Godwin that could
mean that those people will go out and
they will vote for cha Mesa and you can
tell that mana gaga has felt threatened
by this because yesterday he did put out
a video in which he said if you moat for
two Mesa you vote for Mugabe so
apparently he does still have a say only
looking at these two candidates how much
can either of them actually affect
change at least they promise change this
is what they both have been running that
campaigns on especially when it comes to
the economy but talking of the economy
and the disastrous state that it is in
it is quite a difficult task to climb
out of this horrific Liebig hole that
the Mugabe era has duck it will be a
difficult task to bring the economy back
on proper footing and when it comes to
other promises man and Gaga has been
saying he's gonna fight corruption he's
gonna make the country a lot freer but
as you've seen in the report as we've
said he is one of the people who was
part of the very system who was who was
alongside raghava repressing the
opposition and who was responsible for
the economy as well and when it comes to
to Mesa he has been making big promises
too especially when it comes from the
when it comes to the infrastructure but
he doesn't really outline how he's gonna
attain that goal where he's gonna take
the money for for that so for both
change will be a difficult task and what
about the political stability will the
two biggest political parties accept the
results if they lose difficult question
and that's also the biggest concern of
the international observers that we've
been speaking to and will be speaking to
during the day the opposition might not
exact it if Managua wins they have been
saying throughout the entire campaign
that there is rigging going
that the election process is not as
transparent as it should be they were
saying on Saturday that they are certain
that there have been 1 million extra
ballot papers been printed and then we
have the other concern that the military
would not accept it if cha Mesa won the
election and yeah think about it eight
months ago they asked at the President
Mugabe from his office and now eight
months later they're gonna hand over the
power to another party we're not sure
about that so we'll have to see and
we'll keep on following and covering
that for you all right g-dub use Melanie
credible for us in Zimbabwe at a polling
station thank you very much Melanie